when I came to the TL you know I'm I'm
an artist and one of the projects I do
is under Sutter pseudonym and I just the
first person that I met that asked me my
name I just I blurred out my gosh now or
never so I said Rogan and it's having
using a different name it creates this
different version of yourself I mean
you're still you but I like that so it's
good it's like a different I'd say I
have like a slightly different identity
thinking can go either way I guess I'll
just play by it okay cheered you up
every time
I'm from California I was born on Oahu
and my family moved to Daly City when I
was five and we moved to Fresno at the
end of sixth grade when I was 11 and
from Fresno I lived in Fresno until I
was 25 and then that's when I started
moving around I went to Los Angeles and
from Los Angeles I moved to Colorado
after meeting my ex to tax your
convention that we were both working at
and then we got an RV and traveled
around the country for three and a half
years in RV and we came to San Francisco
the first time and I just I fell in love
with the city it's it's amazing here and
I made it a point to come back you know
we had this epic trip that we needed to
take to rescue our friend got we were
gonna rescue our friend from rehab in
Florida and it was a year it took a year
to come back to the city and I've been
here since then that was quite a while
ago now so how was your childhood hey
how was your childhood my childhood um
you know it was it was interesting I
mean everyone has has a it was rough in
some ways both of my parents
were drinkers and my mother worked in
the evening and my dad worked during the
day and so there was a lot of time that
I spent you know just kind of on my own
I really spent most of my time as a kid
on my own I had a best friend and the
fan of their family lived right across
the street from us but other than that I
was kind of longer and my dad was I said
he was an alcoholic and he was also
physically abusive but looking back on
it now I I mean I've long since forgiven
him you know before he passed away
um he was really the only person that
truly got me but I guess you know you
realize your parents are just people and
I don't know how else really he would
have dealt with me it's not right but um
but you know I was really a precocious
child to say the least
and very persuasive and wild and I'm
five and seven years older than my
brothers so I was an only child for a
period of time so I was spoiled and the
center of attention you know at least
when I was really small and when we
lived in Daly City you know as a kid you
don't you know a lot of kids I guess
don't really know your your financial
situation is you don't have any concept
of money and you know compared to you
know different levels of poverty that
exists I can't say that you know we were
that stricken but we were my
grandparents supported us and when my
parents split up I was 14 and
surprisingly my brothers well not for
them but we all went and Linda was my
dad who stayed in an apartment as close
as he could to my mom as possible that
he could not afford and we were just
completely destitute
a friend of mine had a job at Jack and
bucks and that was how we ate which it
was kind of awesome to you know have
those things that you don't really think
about it at the time but it was rough it
was rough
we did drug use start for you I started
using hardcore drugs when I was well 14
and once I started that nose that was it
I actually wanted to be a junkie since I
was a little kid it sounds really weird
but there was something kind of like
romantic about it to me
mysterious and I read a lot a lot and
once I read Jack Kerouac that was it it
was over and I read Big Sur and which
definitely inspired me but my name is
lesser-known books is called Tris Tessa
and it was about this mexican junkie
[ __ ] and that he was in love with and
she just sounds so wild and mysterious
and and untamed and I wanted to I wanted
to be her and I also wanted to be him in
love with her you know just the whole
the whole package it was very enamored
of it all and I have to say that I I
think I've experienced it now I use
heroin and I've done in heroin now for
so long I think that it's it's it's like
a relationship yes I can't imagine that
I can't I really can't imagine parting
ways permanently but I take a break
every once in a while and you know I
have I'm loathe to admit it but I I did
stop for a year and a half once and I
actually was happy but it is I am NOT
unhappy I make my own misery but if I'd
look at my life I have to say that I've
had exactly the life I've wanted his
roughest sometimes have been it's really
exciting and of course as much torture
as I put myself through I realized
actually just last night how little
stress I have in my life I'm so grateful
for that and so just I mean money is
awesome and I feel that this this is
gonna be my year not to say that I
haven't had it and gone through plenty
of it but I just have never really given
a [ __ ] about it and thank God I always
say I can I can be rented we're watching
some reality show and people you know
wealthy people and all their problems
and their stresses and I thought thank
God I don't care about any of that and
we're so lucky
it takes so little no just hang out and
our hotel room or wherever it is at one
point we rented a walk-in closet for $20
a day in this really cool house in
Russian and Russian Hill and we were
happy with that now yeah yeah you mean
on the street no no I've been doing the
the hotel circuit of the Tenderloin for
years now since since I came here
and I'm over it now I'm over it I mean
it's parts it's exciting but now it's
not exciting anymore just rapidly moving
constantly having to move around and I'm
ready now
to do something else I think I've found
some place in North Beach a big
warehouse have you been supporting
yourself varies I've been I have been a
prostitute in some fashion or other
basically my entire life and I'm not
really into it anymore not to say that I
mean
and not that I shunned the idea
definitely it's not the fun that it was
when when I first came here it was like
shangri-la and a lot of women all the
women I know kind of had the same goal
like you it's empowering to you know
find yourself and be sexy and be
somewhere where you know everyone
accepts that and it's not something that
you're judged for and it's something and
people assume about you and correctly
and mmm and it's cool but I just I don't
smoke crack anymore is it
that changes things so I I dabble in
other if there's if there's if there's a
hustle there's some money and I'm into
it did you find the line that you are
willing to cross to make money has
changed over the years yeah over the
years I've I've grown a conscience or I
should say that it's it's matured and I
don't want to I don't want to be greedy
and I don't want to take anything from
anybody you know I don't want anybody to
like just having you're not to say that
you know I'm an angel and I'll probably
be a shoplifter hey I died just just
because but to wreck someone's life to
take their life savings and and they
have no recourse for that that's that's
just not something that I've ever I've
ever been into so you say your moral
compass is changing for the better
yeah as you age yeah I I actually I
think about things now and I didn't used
to definitely but yeah my moral compass
has a it's got direction now dear
friends yeah yeah I find it near to
impossible to maintain communication
with my oldest friends you know my
friends that are not from this
version of my life just like it is if my
my family my immediate family what is
there to say um doing this still you
know and there's there's a certain
amount of shame that that comes with
that and I've got to get over it because
it's really just me I'm really blessed
and that the people I've known for a
really long time
I have always accepted me and picked up
right where we left off and I think the
only person is judging these is me but
that's that can that's for the better
the best as well I mean I need to look
at myself and you know I've got to do
some things myself and it seems like
everything's kind of it's coming to a
head and I feel good I feel good about
the direction I'm going and I don't feel
like it's the last chance I just feel
like it's the it's about time it's such
so you're more hopeful now than you did
in the past yeah definitely if I feel
finally that I have and I have not just
a direction but a vision you know I can
kind of see it coming together and and I
can I've found my my self-worth in there
in that in that mix where before I
doubted myself and I I guess my big deal
is one day you know I would finally find
some success and everyone at the party
would stop and you would hear all the
glasses clink and somebody would say
what is she doing here she's an imposter
kick her out so I don't feel that way
anymore I don't feel that way anymore
yeah
did you find yourself getting depressed
sometimes or oh right yeah I'm really
manic I guess I think that I'm what you
mean living on the street at the art not
to it well like I say I don't I'm not
living on the street right then again
that that could be less stressful than
it sounds you're scrambling for a place
to live
Oh Oh God yeah and now this like since
since the Chrome virus this is this is a
blessing and as at the I don't want to
say at the expense of of so many other
people because it's definitely not been
a blessing to you know a millions of
people I know struggling and losing
loved ones and you know working nonstop
and questions and no no job and so
there's that but for me it's it's it's
been a break and it's been much more
affordable I mean sometimes the hotel is
only $35 a day and as you know San
Francisco is the most expensive city to
live in it was I paid one hundred and
fifty dollars a day for a long time
just to stay at you know the Travel
Lodge so there's this is this is a break
definitely and it couldn't have come at
a better time because I'm just this it's
different now
the scene has changed slowly you know I
don't want to I can't stand outside I'm
not waiting till 8:00 hustle a date and
and for so many reasons
yeah if you have bad experiences both
working as a prostitute or working or
living on the street is hanging out and
really you know I've been really lucky
my whole life um really only one thing
has has ever happened to me that that
was you know really scary dangerous and
horrifying but still I wasn't hurt I am
really lucky and I have this I just
believe fundamentally that nothing truly
bad will ever happen to me and that's
really important
a that belief makes it my reality
nothing has happened to me in the
Tenderloin other than you know just [ __ ]
I put myself through thank God yeah dude
give kids no no kids you been married I
have been married yes a long time ago a
couple of lifetime's
you need the environment you grew up in
as a child somehow led you down this
path well I mean as far as I mean anyone
I think your your childhood definitely
its it shapes you but I don't blame my
childhood I don't look back at my
childhood with any there's no anger
really or resentment I felt it's always
been it's been my independent choice and
it wasn't until I came to the city that
I ever even looked back at like my
teenage years and relished in and how
cool that was because it was a great
source of shame for me like you know I'm
from Fresno and everybody knew about me
and you know some people even saw and it
never struck me what they might actually
be thinking you know I was just like oh
my god you know this is what however
everyone was think I'm so disgusting
this pariah and that really wasn't the
case but it was really cool to be have
no parents no curfew and you know I had
this like rockin girlfriend and we were
idiots and more teenagers so we're still
kids but getting to we had all this
money and you know he's smoking crack of
staying in hotel rooms and it was
amazing it was a blast it was truly a
blast and I have met such amazing people
over the years and had so many weird
experiences you know and not my entire
life has just been you know focused on
the streets I mean I've I've you know
had many different phases and I
definitely think I know I'm an
adrenaline junkie and
I'm kind I'm a little bit of a sexual
degenerate I think a lot of us out here
are maybe the term sex addict but I've
experienced some weird things and
they're and cool things and what's the
craziest thing you um like how we gonna
date or yeah sure um I don't really have
like I mean I never think of my stories
is that weird um I have met some women
people though uh there was this guy that
used to pay me to put an Eminem naked
talk that's not even that weird um oh
I'm just gonna head there's you know the
the whole there's people that want to
pay to eat your [ __ ] and it's referred
to as a a brow I guess around shower
and a golden shower first of all is not
exactly what you what one might think I
mean it's an extremely intimate it's not
you're not just not just pissing onsen
which can be artful and cool and but it
can also be really creepy and intimate
and again I exhort intimate but there
was a guy he was
I met him some night shift which was
amazing once I found that and had like
you website and everything I I met so
many cool people through that um this
guy though he kind of first it was just
about a date and then he revealed to me
that he wanted to do a golden shower and
I knew that this was gonna be you know I
was really gonna be in for something so
I'm like you know stealing myself for it
and then somehow we end up on this topic
and he felt comfortable with me so he
said he wanted to do a brown and I was
like okay you know I mean I want to know
about it like what drives someone want
to do this so I first I you know I
talked to Jersey about it
so what do you think he said you know
I'm right outside I support you did you
know go for it I told him that I would
do it under the condition that he let me
interview him first and record it so I
do have a recorded interview of this and
it I know insight after the interview I
still don't know more than I did when I
started it was just like so what made
you want to be a human toilet it was by
far like hands-down the most disturbing
unsettling experience I've ever what was
his answer to that question like what
why he was into it he told me how see if
there was some this story about his
little sister and and seeing her seeing
her pee and like something that he
wasn't supposed to see like it was this
not anything I think that he's leaving I
I don't know if he is I can't I don't
want to assume that there's some type of
abuse that's involved because I
certainly don't want to judge anyone for
for what they do because I just don't
understand I mean it was never clear to
me it started out as he met this woman
and they started late and just happened
one time she she just she peed while he
was he was going down on her and I can't
I get all that
I wrap my head around it and they had a
very she he was a sub and she was the
Dom how it turns into [ __ ] I still don't
really know one of the most disturbing
things there's there's there's a button
okay the date this person has total
control over you and it's so
psychologically you go to a very
different place than you think you're
going to because it's not all of us not
about them being dominated it's almost
like you are the one because they just
they can make you start and stop what
like this button and there's gagging and
it's either all these thoughts going
through your mind like how could someone
else how can I be doing this and it is
not it's not the dollar amount that you
would think or that it's just everything
about it is
um yeah I was and then he wanted me like
towards the end he wanted me to blow
them like the end of it and I was so I
just wanted to hit him what are you
[ __ ] kidding me
like even if I wasn't making work eating
my [ __ ] psychologically
I can't go there now like that then what
oh is this that that really upset me and
so I did not oblige him um somewhere
there the recording of the whole thing I
still have it never listened to it
I obvious in the beginning the interview
part but um oh so so strange when I was
I was in junior high me and my mom would
walk home after school and there's the
sky and it's like red just Scirocco that
would drive him really slowly and he was
that kind of following his work next to
us and I knew he was doing like it
you're joking off in a car - these -
like preteen girls so one day which I'm
like look if you don't give us some
money we're gonna tell on you so he gave
us five dollars each which was you know
awesome and so we were just go and like
spend that money on candy or whatever
and I knew this guy for years after that
you know like off and on throughout the
years and it escalate other things that
happened there was the foot thing and
then there was also once I went with him
to a car wash and it was sound like you
know the industrial like the vacuum
cleaner that doesn't really stop
daughter I had to hold the hose like he
was getting off like that and so it's
like you know and also ow
but he wanted a woman to step on his
face with their bare butt as dirty as
possible and that was his deal and only
one girl though because $10 was all he
was gonna pay for it and I have
discovered throughout my trials in life
$10 is all anyone ever paid for that but
I asked him like what is it that why do
you want to be you know mean this way
like tell me about it he's reckless it's
not me that is I'm getting what I want
you know I'm he had a foot
you said that part of his thrill was
getting somebody to compromise their own
values for such a nominal amount that's
interesting yeah blew my mind and that's
what I was thinking of during this Wow
it's very interesting yeah what advice
would you give to a young person young
girl perhaps who's reading the the work
of Jack Kerouac and and into this
alternative world and attracted to it
before she gets into it make some of the
moves that you did early on made it hard
to reverse I think that um one's own
belief in oneself maintaining your
self-confidence and just being genuine
it's the best thing you just you are
yourself in spite of yourself as long as
you're genuine you'll be okay
learn from your mistakes as long as as
you're learning you're growing and I
feel that I something even if it's my
new everyday like something can change
something grows and as long as that's
happening then you're living being be
genuine so that sometimes that's all
there is that's all you have this life
can be so hard and you can get so down
on yourself and so ground down but you
can always be grateful for that if
you're really if you're being true to
yourself and if you're good to yourself
and you're good to other people
excellent okay Robert thank you so much
for talking with me a very interesting
time
[Laughter]